we have a lot of Swedish sayings that  are very commonly used and it's one of  those things when it's my own language I  didn't really think about how weird they  are but saying in Swedish well now  you've taken a poop in the blue cabinet  yeah  it's like a very common thing or like  yeah you can't just expect yourself you  know to walk in here like sliding in on  a shrimp sandwich  can't come in here and slide on a shrimp  sandwich  you know in a socialist country having a  shrimp sandwich is very fancy so it's  not like you can't just have your  privileges and walk in slide in here on  a shrimp sandwich we have an Australian  one uh we're not here to [ __ ] spiders  [ __ ]